this is from euronews.com I don't think
I've ever read a headline from them it
says an American journalist has claimed
that he was detained on Monday after
trying to enter World the World Cup
stadium in Qatar where same-sex
relationships are outlawed while wearing
a rainbow shirt in support of the LGBT
community so this is Grant Wall is his
name and he put a picture up there very
proudly he's got the he's got the
rainbow flag and he says just now
security guard refusing to let me into
the stadium for USA whales you have to
change your shirt it's not allowed he
says uh he says that he was
um
taken away and that he was detained for
nearly a half hour but then he says that
they uh that they had later apologized
to him and let him into the let him into
the country so that's what he says
happen
and we're seeing stunts like this and
usually the stunt is is quickly
abandoned there have been various
including the USA team you know
originally they were talking about
rainbow Flags changing uniform and they
didn't really end up doing that but they
did have I think in their practice
facility they had the rainbow flags all
over the place so
we're getting this from these from uh
some of these Western people that are
showing up there
um
but you just see it's interesting how
quickly
the respect all culture stuff
goes out the window isn't it
I mean say what you want but
this is Qatar it's their country
it's a non-western non-white country
and now you've got white people white
westerners like Grant Wall showing up
and saying I don't respect your Customs
I don't respect your your beliefs I'm
going to do what I want in your country
I'm going to tell you how you should run
your country
your laws don't mean anything to me
because I'm the white western guy and
I'll I'll tell you I will influ I will
show up and be and be the uh and and be
the the Arbiter of morality
the source of morality
it is a it is a form of this kind of
moral colonialism
that you see from the West this
ideological colonialism
that you see almost uniquely these days
from the left
and yet in any other context these same
people would claim that they're all
about multiculturalism well you don't
care about multiculturalism if you're
not accepting a person's culture
including the parts of it you don't like
so if you're saying I'm a
multiculturalist I enjoy
multiculturalism
um I enjoy all cultures and I respect
all cultures except for the parts of
those cultures I don't personally prefer
and that don't line up with my values
well if that's the case then you don't
believe in multiculturalism and you
don't respect other cultures
it's kind of like saying I respect all
free speeches except for the speech that
I don't like well then you don't respect
free speech
so it all goes out the window
immediately
and also I I do have to say and there
have been uh some you know Qatari
citizens who have uh
spoken out about this here's one for
example says as a Qatari I'm proud of
what happened I don't know when will the
westerners realize that their values
aren't Universal there are other
cultures with different values that
should be equally respected let's not
forget that the West is not the
spokesperson for Humanity now we talked
about this a little bit yesterday and um
you had the president of FIFA that was
saying well the West has a lot to
apologize for but he meant historically
he was taking about taking him back
three thousand years and so he was doing
the whole white guilt routine going back
3000 years in all of our and all of our
dastardly sins
um that is absurd
but if we're talking about modern day
for talking about the West in in modern
times the West right now
I would agree that we just are not in a
position to morally lecture anyone I'm
afraid to say
we in the west are not in a position
so we can put ourselves in a pedestal
and say oh those look at those those
qataris and their disgusting laws they
have no respect for human decency
we're just not in a position to assume
the moral High Ground we don't have the
moral High Ground we surrendered it
in this country we did
it's very sad to say but it's true
like we talked about yesterday we live
in a country
uh in in in in modern times where we
execute
we've executed 60 million babies in the
womb
60 million
and if you believe that those are human
beings then you believe that in our
country we and I say we in the general
sense are responsible for arguably the
worst Mass Slaughter of the innocent
that's ever happened on the planet
and then to make matters worse we also
castrate sterilize our kids we don't
even have a a sense of you know what a
man or woman is anymore we're just
utterly completely confused
we celebrate evil and debauchery in its
most deranged forms that's what we do in
this country
and then we think that we're in a
position to go and
ideologically colonize the globe and
tell them they need to be more like us
well the problem is that the other
countries when we say that when we give
that pitch and we say you should be more
like us
well the members of the other country
they look at us
like freaks they look at us like a bunch
of confused weirdos they they look at us
and say well I don't want to be like you
why would I want to be like you
mean over in your country where you
think that men can get pregnant
I mean over your country where you're
sterilizing little boys to turn them
into girls
you are surgically and medically
altering little boys to make them girls
and you think we want to be like you
it's just it's not a convincing sales
pitch
I noticed this when I was over uh when
we were in Kenya and it was it was very
sad to see
that the people in Kenya they look at
America Now with uh really it's like a
it's almost like a paternalistic
pity
like a kind of there there you sad
confused children sort of thing
when they hear about what's happening
here and can you blame them
you saw in the film I asked one of them
you know would you ever want to move to
America and they laughed they laughed at
the idea
that they would ever want to move here
that's what we have made of ourselves on
the world stage
Remember When Donald Trump was President
we heard so much handwringing and
fretting from the left about how we
won't be respected on the world stage
in other countries I don't care about
who the president is whether it's Donald
Trump or someone else
it's about the culture
okay they're not they're looking at our
politics they're looking at our culture
and these non-western countries are
seeing our culture and seeing a culture
that has that is just
caving in on itself that is eating
itself
and uh they're saying I just I'm not
interested in your moral lectures can
you blame them I can't I just can't
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as you move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]